Hugo es un amante del peligro,
le gusta ir a escalar dentro de volcanes activos...
¡realmente le gusta el peligro a este amigo!
Acaba de escuchar un ruido alarmante
y decide salir del volcán lo más rápido posible.
La elevación de hugo relativa al borde del cráter del volcán (medida en metros)
y la vamos a denotar por "E",
como función del tiempo (en segundos) que está denotado por "t",
se muestra en la tabla a continuación.
Hugo escala a una velocidad constante.
Y bien nos preguntan,
basándote en la tabla,
¿cuál de los siguientes enunciados debe ser verdadero?
de estos enunciados de acá.
Y bueno si nos fijamos en los enunciados
todos nos están hablando de
¿cuál era la distancia?
¿la elevación de Hugo relativa al cráter?
y ¿cuál era su velocidad de escalada al salir?
por lo tanto, vamos a tratar de usar esta tabla de aquí,
para averiguar esos datos.
Y bien lo primero que voy a hacer,
es modificar un poco esta tabla
porque si se fijan no está en un modo estándar.
Generalmente tenemos la variable
independiente del lado izquierdo
y la variable dependiente del lado derecho.
Así que voy a tomar esto de aquí...
esto de aquí...
y lo voy a cortar...
y lo voy a pegar por acá.
Muy bien,
más o menos algo así queda.
Bien, entonces,
ya que tengo esto escrito de este modo,
que al menos en mi mente es más sencillo verlo así,
vamos a hacer un pequeño dibujo
para entender la situación.
Si digamos,
este es el cráter de mi volcán...
el cráter de mi volcán...
y...
digamos esta es la falda del volcán...
aquí, por acá, no sé...
por ahí está la lava ardiendo...
y probablemente esté saliendo humo y cosas así...
y vamos a decir que este puntito aquí,
es precisamente Hugo
que está tratando de salir del volcán...
está dentro del volcán y quiere salir,
y entonces esta tabla nos mide,
o nos dice,
después de cuánto tiempo de que empezó a escalar,
¿cuánto ha subido?
¿o cuánto se ha elevado?
Noten que como el cráter,
está más arriba que Hugo,
la elevación de Hugo siempre es negativa respecto al cráter,
eso significan estos signos menos de acá.
Pero bueno,
vamos a tratar de entender lo que pasa,
quiero encontrar primero el punto inicial de Hugo,
la elevación inicial de Hugo cuando decide salir,
y para eso noto que en el tiempo "t" iguala 0,
"t" igual a 0,
la elevación de Hugo está en -24 metros,
por lo tanto esta instancia original,
que color usamos, vamos a usar este...
esta distancia original, cuando Hugo decide salir,
es de 24 metros.
Y ahora vamos a encontrar su velocidad, para hacer eso, pues podemos utilizar la razón de cambio,
cuando el tiempo aumenta en 4 segundos,
cuando transcurren 4 segundos,
delta, acuérdense,
delta mayúscula significa cambio en,
el cambio en "t" de 4 unidades positivas,
eso es un 4,
y a eso, le corresponde un cambio en la elevación
¿de cuánto?
Pues el cambio en la elevación
es de...
quizás debería usar otro color...
vamos a usar este verde...
el cambio en la elevación de Hugo es,
¿de cuánto?
pues pasó de estar a -24 metros a -21 metros,
por lo tanto tiene un cambio positivo
de 3 metros en su elevación.
De donde si yo quisiera
calcular la velocidad a la que está escalando Hugo,
tendría que decir,
cuántas unidades de elevación, cuántos metros ha escalado
dividido entre
cuántos segundos han pasado
y eso me daría su velocidad.
Entonces, ¿cuánto es el cambio en la elevación?
pues es 3
y el cambio en la...
y el cambio en el tiempo perdón,
pues el cambio en el tiempo es de 4 segundos,
por lo tanto tengo que
la velocidad de Hugo es de
tres cuartos de metro sobre segundo.
Incluso podría ser una pequeña gráfica,
eso también ayudaría, vamos a hacer una gráfica,
voy a poner este eje de aquí,
que va a ser mi eje de elevación
y como la mayoría de las elevaciones,
aquí en mi tabla son negativas,
también voy a poner
el eje del tiempo, de modo que tenga
bastantes números negativos a mi disposición.
Este es el eje el tiempo y el eje de la elevación.
y bueno,
entonces yo sé que cuando el tiempo,
está en 0,
cuando estoy aquí,
cuando Hugo decide salir,
está a una elevación de -24 metros,
digamos hasta por aquí...
-24 metros.
Y yo sé que cuando uno llega al borde del cráter,
que es precisamente cuando su elevación es cero,
han transcurrido 32 segundos
de que empezó a escalar,
así que aquí,
está en "t" igual a 32.
de modo que,
la velocidad con la que Hugo escala,
o más bien, esta es la gráfica que denota la posición de Hugo respecto al borde del cráter,
con relación al tiempo.
Y la pendiente de esta gráfica,
va a ser precisamente la velocidad de Hugo,
así se interpreta la pendiente de esta gráfica de aquí,
y esa velocidad,
es de tres cuartos de metro sobre segundo,
de hecho,
chequen, por ejemplo,
si pasara de 4 a 12,
entonces tengo un cambio en el tiempo,
un cambio en el tiempo de 8.
Como es el doble del cambio del tiempo,
esperaría que el cambio en la elevación
también fuera el doble que este 3,
y de -21 a -15 también hay un cambio,
en la elevación de 6...
8 perdón...
6 entre 8,
de nuevo son tres cuartos de metros sobre segundo,
pero bueno, chequemos las respuestas.
Hugo estaba 24 metros bajo el cráter
cuando decide salir
y escala 3 metros cada 4 segundos durante su salida.
Pues efectivamente está a -24 metros,
y
lo que acabamos de calcular, que es su velocidad,
si nos dice que escala 3 metros cada 4 segundos,
por lo tanto ésta parece ser correcta,
Hugo estaba 24 metros bajo el cráter cuando decide salir y escala 4 metros cada 3 segundos.
¡Pues no! acabamos de checar
que escala 3 metros cada 4 segundos,
no 4 metros cada 3 segundos,
por lo tanto esto está mal.
Hugo estaba 32 metros bajo el cráter...
ahí ya puedo decir que estaba, mal esta opción,
porque Hugo está a -24 metros,
o sea a 24 metros del cráter.
Hugo estaba a 32 metros bajo el cráter
cuando decide salir,
de nuevo,
Hugo estaba a 24 metros bajo el cráter.
Así que la opción correcta es esta primera de aquí.